all right q
q uh where'd you grow up where are you
from originally i'm from chicago
illinois
cook county chicago south side south
side
tell me about your childhood both with
your parents as a kid
yeah i had both of my parents as a kid
um
grew up a little bit and then i realized
that i had a different
but i had a different biological
biological father was different
then who raised you yeah then who raised
me yeah so uh
i began to go over there to you know
that side of the family for summer
when they i stayed in the suburb harvey
they lived in chicago
south side so i would start going over
there over there for the summer and
that's where i kind of got
they kind of just let me run wild over
there because they haven't seen me for
like 13 years
it was my first time you know being back
around them because my mom
allowed me to go back over there and
that's kind of when i uh kind of started
seeing things for the first time like
my dad was a gang member
a pimp drug dealer a theme
but he was cool as hell though with me
he was real cool
so i remember one time coming downstairs
and uh
they trying to make me stay upstairs and
uh from coming in the basement
but i kind of slipped through there
anyway i ran down to that little twirl
stairs so i kind of ran down the stairs
and i stopped
and i remember i seen uh having my uncle
arguing when they were wrapping this
lady up in the carpet
like rolling her in the carpet like a
like a big ass joint you know like
rolling the ruck
and they was fighting and then they say
uh they saw me they stopped fighting he
came down there they both got up and
they came to me like i don't know what
they want to do to me i was gonna get in
trouble
and then the lady and the carpet start
making noises and moving
then when they unrolled her from the
carpet she started laughing and they
started laughing too
and they picked her up you know and they
sat down like everything was all right
and he was like you know we thought you
were the davise you know
i roll you up and throw you up out of
there and they started uh i started
laughing i
remember i remember that [ __ ] i was kind
of young on that
but i was staying with my dad out there
my uh the man who raised me he's a
police officer
he ended up going to jail for
basically selling drugs while wearing a
uniform
to to gang members like to they would
rob
black stones and you can basically like
give uh against the disciples the
cellulite to disciples the drugs they
would sell them the drugs
so my dad ended up getting in trouble
for that and they started uh
one day they just came to the house and
they just came and took them
fbi but most of them was ladies for some
reason they all came they came in the
house they took them and [ __ ] took them
to jail
my mom ended up moving to california i
didn't want to move out there that we
know about out here california so i
ended up staying in chicago
and you know i started smoking uh you
know smoking weed drinking every day my
biological father ended up dying
and my family kind of like got shifty on
me so as i
started hanging with my friends more
hanging with my friends they was
i didn't realize how much they were like
the [ __ ] they was into
but like i realized that the gang [ __ ]
was real once we got out of our our
neighborhood and i ride around with them
and i remember one time i'm riding in
the car
and somebody's following us on we're
trying to get off the fleet to dan ryan
and someone who's trying to exit like
150th or some [ __ ] like they were trying
to exit
and the car kept on following so he i
remember my friend uh
one of my friends he drove to the gas
station and then i was sitting in the
front seat
and the two the two people in the back
seat of our car
as soon as the car stopped they just got
out the car they got the car to shot
like this and start shooting
boom boom boom boom boom boom my one
friend started shooting and as his
gun finished shooting to his last bullet
my other friend like right after this it
sounded like one long drill like
because right after he stopped shooting
his started shooting
and i remember the car backing up and i
remember that the door
the doors i opened up in their car
remember the car backing up with the
door still open
hitting the um hitting running like a
little pose
hitting that [ __ ] and somebody falling
out the car and hitting their face on
the curb
i remember seeing first hit his face on
the curb real hard like oh
i i never seen nobody get shot but i
remember how the man fell down
and it looked uh he fell down fast like
extra fast like boom
so he fell down and because it is
i guess um they found out the person
driving the car i was in the car with i
was sitting in the car with him that
night
i mean to the morning from night to the
morning i sit in the car with him
these guys from um i think they were
actually they was from uh
it's robert taylor home to robert taylor
yeah yeah
i think there's from there that's where
we just came from anyway they started
shooting we were sitting in the car my
friend i was in the car with him
he started driving backwards and it was
a field behind us with a power plant
like there's like a big power box a
great power box and i remember they
started shooting at us the two guys
started running at us like this they had
straps
the guns were just hanging like they was
running that car i
i really didn't know what to think i was
just like looking at the dude he started
looking for his keys he started driving
backwards through about 40 backwards he
hit the green power box
in a whole open field you know if he
could have just missed a little
power box i think we could have just
drove away from them but from him
hitting that power box the two people
they start opening up they start opening
fire
so i jumped in the back seat he tried to
jump in the back seat too but he got
shot and he fell back in the front seat
and i remember uh i'm ducking down he
started shooting up the car he started
shooting back
i remember just staying down for a long
time hearing people gathering around the
car
i remember the ambulance was coming my
friend brian who i got shot
i guess he was like he wasn't fully
conscious and the ambulance was coming
to try to help him and then he started
shooting at the ground because he heard
footsteps and they stopped the ambulance
and they didn't come in the car and i
sat in the car and i watched him die
because
that you know they didn't want to come
to the car because he's still shooting
not trying to tell them like you know i
would i wanted to reach for the gun but
i didn't want to touch the gun like
because i remember i know police was
coming
i seen police coming and [ __ ] i was
trying to tell him to come and help him
but they wouldn't help him because he
started shooting up the grass
like you know so after this my mom got
terrified i ended up moving out here to
california
uh you stayed in chicago yeah i stayed i
stayed out there i came out here to
visit my mom though
after that incident south side of
chicago is no joke no it's no joke it's
uh
no there's no joke uh i got i'm like
it's like i'm like the one i'm like
there's only two like male family
members left on uh
my dad's side my real my biological
father he died my cousin
was like all my older cousins they're
all dead they was all males and they all
been shot they all been shot they're all
all shot gangster recycled yeah yeah
and you became one as well yeah
yeah but i wasn't like i mean i i know i
didn't know better that's what
that's what they were they already was
there for jenny like you know
my uncle my cousin has been me you know
i really didn't
i didn't see it there's no gang or
nothing like you know it's just
everybody called each other g around
there you know and i know they beat up
on people and [ __ ] but
it isn't like you join or you don't join
it's just like it is what it is yeah no
it's a it's a
it's a it's a it's a [ __ ] gang and
they they
they hurt people when they live it's
like they live on a it's a borderline
like it's so crazy over there because
it's yeah you got this it's like this
one street
and in between it on this side
you know uh blackstone on the other side
you had gangster disciples
now i wanted against disciples to go
over there and do something to one of
the black stones or they'll shoot each
other on that little
on that uh you know on a border line
there's a lot of killers happening on
the borderline
and after one of the guys disabled do
something it's like they'll go further
back into their blocks
so they and it's harder for them to come
and get them because they got to go
further further into the blocks you know
so then they started uh basically paying
other gang members to kill their own
gang members they started doing that and
then rappers out there a lot of rappers
started getting money out there too
that was really truly gang members and
that [ __ ] started a lot of [ __ ] because
they got on tv and
uh you know youtube and on instagram and
all that [ __ ] and they were talking
about the [ __ ] that they done
to each other and let's just start a
bunch of
whole bunch of mess like you know some
people really started getting killed
uh chicago did you feel like you had
even a
choice in it or just something you just
no no
you know choice no it it's so [ __ ] up
out there like
somebody can't run on the school
somebody went on a uh a public bus and
shot somebody
now you know somebody got shot on a
public bus they shot up uh
i was going to go to a picnic on on
easter
and somebody shot up the picnic shot 13
people seven kids
uh one of my uncle he got he got shot in
the back and he's walking in between
three people he got shot in the back by
somebody
and then they ended up trying to run
away and they end up hitting a little
kid
a little kid um his name was marshawn
and he was in the stroller
mama got mama pushed and got hit by a
lot of [ __ ] who uh
didn't hit the shooting and
chicago
and chicago is uh i don't know i think
they need the national guard or some
[ __ ] out there
yeah the number of murders the number of
murderers out there yeah they need the
national guard out there
and then uh it's that it's a law like
you can
it's it's like something we if you get
caught with a gun it's like you get out
the next day
type [ __ ] like some [ __ ] like that like
you get out the next day
you know and like i don't know
the cops can't really do a whole lot
about it no the cops don't know they
can't they can't really they can't
it's a lot of bad a lot of bando
buildings out there too
and they're kind of like making them
like the little bases the cops they
they kind of get there they let the
shooting and the [ __ ] calm down then
they'll come
kind of kind of come clean and clean it
up but for the most part
they tore down all the projects at one
time in chicago
and that misplaced ten thousand people
and he ten thousand people got spread it
out through chicago
which was mostly gang members drug
dealers you know uh
dope things because but they were all
contained into these uh projects
when they tore down them projects that
[ __ ] spread it out everywhere so i was
like
gangster disciples would have had to
move with their like say your auntie
who lives in the blackstone neighborhood
and a lot of [ __ ] start happening like
that plus when they got put out they got
they got hit with a little money since
they got their houses torn down you know
i think the government whatever gave
them like a little money a couple of
thousands which they
bought guns and drugs with you know
started fighting and
i don't think chicago knew what it meant
to mis misplaced that many people
at one time you know they didn't think
they realized that
that [ __ ] was going to happen like that
that's why the murder race super
skyrocketed to be honest
they tore down all the projects what are
the main sources of income
for the gangs out there in chicago oh
heroin selling heroin
heroin or crack or
basically robbing each other uh i know
they were doing jewelry heights and [ __ ]
they were doing that uh
a lot but they got their jewelry like
stores and everything so so locked up
tight up there in chicago now
yeah they're basically selling heroin
and correct
yeah the black everybody doing black out
there like even the young people
young people was on their own black dude
black like i had a younger people out
here do
do crystal they they don't think about
no crystal out there they do black
so you can imagine when a young gang
member and
is kind of feeding for that [ __ ] you
know and they get upset you know they
started
killing the hell out of people and even
prison time
no no i never been in prison i never
been to prison
i had a couple of d.a rejects
out here that was about it i
i never done i've never done prison
clothes i've been to prison my
my about my my stepdad being locked up
for doing a fair time
so you're one of the few male family
members that's in your family that
survived and
yeah and you never got any prison time
no no i didn't what's your secret
guys grace i guess i mean i i've been in
a car accident where
the driver died and the two people in
the back seat had their pelvis just
shattered
there wasn't nothing wrong with me at
all
um i kind of got a knack for
i i'll get i'll i'll leave a
[ __ ] area if ain't got nothing
to do with me and i can i can send so i
could tell like you know some [ __ ]
gonna happen all right especially like
today i'll just get up and leave because
i
i seen like a little things turn into
trying tell people like hurting each
other for real like one time
this lady she was uh arguing with her
husband or some [ __ ]
you know all nighters people stay in our
apartments she his her husband got mad
he went outside
his name was his name was uh his name
was denver he's shooting dice he's
shooting dice with
friends and [ __ ] so anyway the lady
comes outside holding the baby
she comes outside holding the baby she
gets in her car she pulls up to where
he's at she get out the car holding her
baby mind you
shoots him in the head gets in the car
with her baby
and drives off i didn't see her shoot
him but i saw her walk out the car and i
heard the gunshot and i saw her walk
back in that car
like the baby like you know at chicago
uh
i seen um uh
my one of my mom friends we was uh all
barbecuing
he went outside one day he was talking
to the guy in the car he talked to some
guys in the car
and the guy in the car was like stick a
gun up something he's like hey i ain't
scared i'm scared he's like what
the dude said like that he threw his
hands up
saved his life but shot his arms up and
then the car pulled out earl and dude
turned around he said [ __ ] uh bullet
holes
in his arm they weren't even bleeding it
was a dark circle
they weren't even bleeding yet you know
and he was like this and i was i
remember thinking like damn him him
flinching like that saved his life you
know you know cause that [ __ ] would have
flew right he would
he would shot that man right in his face
like this [ __ ] life crazy
uh i lost i lost three three friends to
uh
uh gun play playing with guns when i was
in middle school and [ __ ] they playing
with guns
uh one of my friends shot another shot
one of my friends in the chest
with a gauge uh the other two friends
um shot themselves in the head with like
little guns um
my my dad my dad he uh
he got mad at us one day because we was
you know we didn't know what he was into
and i remember we were playing in the
garage you know and he thought that we
told you he talked to somebody breaking
in the garage he came down there with
his [ __ ] gun like you know
he's like we thought he was playing he
shot that [ __ ]
and we oh we all around the corner he's
like man what y'all doing like i know at
the time like
he was on trial and gangster disciples
was coming and calling at him and [ __ ]
like he was all sketchy
like you only blew our head off
yeah yeah chicago they got a uh
oh they got a like they got these
basements right they got basements
you know they got they ain't got
basements out here too much yeah
yeah they got a lot of basements and
that's what they stockpiled like they
got they got hello weapons down there in
chicago hello weapons in the basements
just triangle clips
i i seen um i seen a a little gun
a little nine millimeter my cousin had a
little nine millimeter had a clip like
this longhorn
a little gun do you think there's any
help for the
chicago getting better
yeah they got it they got to get the uh
the schools and [ __ ] and everything they
got to get everything back oh they gotta
get something to do they need something
to do
you know the um
they gotta start putting [ __ ] in jail
for having for just having a gun
for just having one you know that's they
gotta do
but they need the national guard out
there or something and i also thought
about this like well
maybe chicago is so violent because
vietnam
drafted the most people out of america
came out of cook county
80 000. came out of cook county chicago
and i'm guessing they came back from the
war they started having babies with
like 70 80s babies you know like and i
think i think maybe they had something
to do with like you know just like the
violence and the killing and the
shooting
like everybody know how to shoot out
there like really know how to shoot
you know they have like real shootouts
then heroin addiction came from vietnam
as well
that's why i saw my black out there huh
and she tried that's why they that's all
they do out there that's great i ain't
really
realize that that the heroine came from
um
came from vietnam a lot of people came
back from vietnam with heroin addiction
he said that she wasn't
out here until until vietnam huh
so you moved to l.a at what point um
2000 2011 but i thought the last time
i'm in chicago like 2013.
um how do you find la
compared to chicago
oh i never i i've never seen like so
many um hispanics and stuff like
it's it's kind of open like everybody is
like you can do what you want to do out
here like
chicago is more like kind of tight and
probably like more private with their
you know more but out here it's like
like how you just came outside with no
shirt on like what's up man you know
talking and [ __ ] like you never really
see no [ __ ] out there like that in
chicago too much you know
yeah you're staying on skid row huh
you're staying on skate row right now i
went to la grande
i i i mean i just left from down here
skid row for like
yeah i've been i've only been on um at
the la grande for like two
two months and it's like but but skid
row is kind of an open
like an area where all the gang is kind
of coaching oh yeah yeah yeah skid row
it's not like south central where the
secretary you know no i know not out
here
it's kind of like you know you're on
busy like
in chicago they would never let each
other sell each other sell drugs out
here like how everybody just doing what
they want to do and
they would never they would never have
it that they would get rid of that yeah
they would
they'll be killing people out here like
no we're going we want to sell drugs and
all these blocks like
it's a lot more structure and like you
know peace like
in that lady people realize downtown
skid row like this people eating
man cigarettes alone gotta be making a
million million dollars
like [ __ ] every two days or something
just cigarettes alone being sold out
here
alone from the cubans you know that's
just gotta
they got that cigarette [ __ ] on lock
that makes the most money out here
cigarettes
it's the cigarettes but yeah this is um
and spice
and crack crack and heroin cracked black
cabbie cheaters
this is the yeah melting melting pot of
drill you get whatever you want right
here
it's like uh it's the illest place in
america it's got to be though all right
this is got to be the craziest place in
america it's pretty crazy because
it's pretty crazy the police station is
right there
at least know what's going on yeah it's
like it's kind of like they're not going
to
keep it contained and yeah just keep it
contained
it doesn't spread out of this
neighborhood and it's like you'll see it
start spreading it's a chance to start
and then the chance to be gone like
they're just like it's
it's it's crazy as [ __ ] but now it's
like they're trying to get everybody
apartments like they're trying to give
them to you yeah
they're trying to give them to you you
know what i mean like i don't know i
think
the olympics is coming out here or some
[ __ ] no they're trying to get people off
the street
yeah automatically but you know the
olympics is coming out here it's gonna
be
and they they like them you know well my
money [ __ ] to come running down
you know fourth and crocker and see all
this [ __ ] they're like you
san francisco [ __ ] up too yes it's got
the same problem but it's but it's
getting smaller and smaller just like
skid row is and then everybody's dying
out here like on skid row like
everybody my friend alabama just died he
just got he got killed or some [ __ ]
every day and it's like i remember that
[ __ ] been dying
and i was like i know the people that
are dying for real like
i i do things with them like you know uh
you know we we uh trade or whatever you
want to call it like i'm actually
interacting with the people that are
dying now and it's like
i just seen him the other day he's
getting high smiling laughing it's like
now he's dead there's three different
stories behind it but this is like the
ninth time this [ __ ] happened already
like
this year you know you know what i mean
it's a federal uh
i don't know what the [ __ ] is where that
fed noise came from are drugs
part of your life no no it is but it
ain't like
i lost i know a lot of people who died
from it
you know a lot of people who've been in
like relate they were in relationships
and now like they're there
their mate has passed away and [ __ ] like
yeah and
like uh my one friend he videotaped
himself
hitting it i just recorded smoke and he
died on
recording himself died on the camera and
he's recording up until the point
of my friend vicki walking up to the
camera seeing him dead crying and
cutting the camera off
yeah so it's like we're looking at the
footage he showed it to us
he hits the uh fentanyl and it's like he
blows his own [ __ ] spirit out like he
blows his
own life out like you know and it's like
that's crazy as [ __ ]
they don't know what they take that
chance you know that's crazy as [ __ ]
you have kids yeah i have a daughter i
have a daughter mercy
uh see right now she's not seated in
harbor city with her mom and my grandma
in harvard city
you see her and i i just started talking
to her
this year recently i seen over the phone
i haven't seen her in person yet
you know i wasn't going to see her one
like a month ago but
i i saw her but
it was so many family members with her
that i kind of turned around you know
what i mean because
that wasn't a plan a plan was going to
be meet her and my mom
my i got a bunch of people came and i i
kind of bitched out
turned around and called my mom like you
know where all the people
[Music]
about your the way you grew up
if it had been different might have set
your life on a different
path i think if my
dad wasn't um if he didn't if he ever
went to jail for that
for being a crooked cop or whatever and
like
your stepdad yeah my stepdad i think my
life would i'm not blaming him for
anything i think my life would have been
totally different like you know i
probably i know i would have stayed i
would have stayed in school
for sure how far did you go in school uh
when anyway
i'm like a sophomore like my sophomore i
was playing basketball and stuff
like i was basically good i got my
little funny and summertime in chicago
when my dad left and then my mom she
went to california
i was like i was receiving money from
like different family members and [ __ ]
like
but i i'm staying with two strippers and
my younger friend uh tarana he stayed
with two strippers and
you know them [ __ ] they're so fine
they give me that
y'all just give it to them you know you
know like whatever they just gonna have
sex on me i just give them whatever [ __ ]
i hate whenever i got it
so i i think things would have been a
lot different
but i i wouldn't have probably had the
upbringing and all the fun that i had
if he didn't sell drugs as a cop like
you know i i had a great i had a fun
um upbringing like sleepovers and [ __ ]
every weekend
i was at that house i had a minivan and
[ __ ] when i was 15.
you know i had fun like a [ __ ]
right now 36. you're 36. you're still
young
yeah i mean i don't i don't think i
think i didn't owe this i thought i was
old when i started seeing people in the
nba younger than me i
i felt like i was all tripping on that
[ __ ]
36 you still got plenty of time to yeah
change direction and where do you see
your see your life going now
36
right now i i i just want i want to get
my i just want to get my housing lock
locked in and get that all settled
really
i work anywhere there to hire me for the
most part probably get that like low
income housing
locked down that's all i'm really uh
concerned about right now
so i'm waiting on my id to come
uh basically just like you know just
take those small steps like get my id
do all the paperwork and everything all
the requirements i need to do to get my
low income
housing or whatever and just kind of
kind of go from there try to find like a
whatever job uh loading trucks
anything uh uh i
i had i had a good time selling drugs
for a while but
i had this club he was a he was gay dude
named man but he ended up getting locked
up you know what i mean
fed so but he was giving me like a pound
of crystal every two days
and i was selling it to the people that
i actually used to buy crystal from
you know i became there their plug but
he went to jail so that that [ __ ]
stopped
yeah well all i can tell you is probably
steering clear of the drugs and the
gangs might be a better father uh yeah
yeah but i mean
that's all that's all i ever kind of
knew was like kind of like
gang members or that's the problem the
environment you grew up in
takes a young man and just that's all he
knows
right your dad your dads were no robot
role models
yeah no they were your friends were all
doing the same thing yeah for the most
part
how many lawyers and doctors and things
like that do you know
as a kid i have a i have an auntie that
works for the fbi
i think that's about it
i knew i knew a few uh i know a few a
few i know i know a few lawyers i knew a
few
i knew a lot of police officers too that
wasn't i'm guessing it wasn't crooked
though you know what i mean
yeah i met i met a few people
but uh i don't really know their answers
like that
i just see them and they'll see me and
be like hey you know like i ain't really
know him for the most part
everybody i know they ain't i know that
i was like one of the only people that
had uh had a dad
really i remember that i remember my
friend i'm telling him he was envious of
that [ __ ]
wait what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned
in your life it wasn't for a lesson i
learned in my life uh
hmm
[Music]
accepting people for who they are and
realizing
you know don't you can't change this
you're either going to accept some [ __ ]
or just don't deal with them no more i
learned that
it's a good one yeah accepting accepting
people for who they are
all right q thank you so much for
sharing your story man
you